problema número 79 cuál es el dominio de
la función mostrará en la siguiente
figura la palabra función suena algo
sofisticado pero en realidad una función
es una regla que relaciona un conjunto
de datos con otro conjunto entonces
quedamos que la función va a relacionar
un conjunto de datos origen que llamamos
dominio hacia un conjunto de datos que
llamamos
rango así que tenemos aquí por ejemplo
un conjunto de números que es el dominio
y tenemos otro conjunto de números que
es el rango
y vamos a tener que la función nos va a
relacionar o a mapear un número del
dominio hacia un número en el rango
normalmente el dominio son todos los
números para los cuales esta relación o
función está definida ahora veamos aquí
en la gráfica el dominio son los números
para los cuales está definida la función
y en general se van a mostrar en el eje
de las x en este eje se va a mostrar el
dominio y el rango está en el eje de las
yes en este eje
una función es el mapeo de x hay en este
caso con nuestros ejes que podemos decir
que también está una función en este
caso va a ser un mapeo de x o una
relación de los datos de x hacia los de
ella
esta función está definida por tenemos
aquí un valor en 4
en 5
en 2 y en 1 aquí nuestro dominio va a
estar compuesto de los números 1
2 4 y 5 son para los únicos en donde
tenemos un valor en g y a cada uno de
estos valores vemos que alguno le
corresponde al menos 4 a éste le
corresponde al menos 42 en x le
corresponde el menos cinco en que menos
5 al 4 le corresponde al menos uno en y
el 5 le corresponde el menos 2
entonces esto de aquí es el dominio
dominio y esto de aquí abajo es el rango
y como nos preguntan cuál es el dominio
de la función pues es esto
1245 es la respuesta de este problema y
pasemos al último problema de esta serie
espero que que para las gráficas hay
apenas pero sí
número 80 cuál de las siguientes no es
una función entonces recordemos lo que
acabamos de ver una función va a ser un
mapeo de un conjunto de números
a otro conjunto de números b para cada
valor del conjunto de a este es mi
conjunto a va a existir un valor
correspondiente en el conjunto b tengo
un número a quien tendré un valor en b
no podemos tener un valor en a que tenga
dos valores en b no puedo tener el mismo
valor en nada con dos valores distintos
en b esto no se puede en una función un
valor de x si éste fueran los valores en
x por ejemplo aquí ya con nuestros
ejemplos que tenemos y esos los valores
en y en una función un valor de x no
puede tener dos valores en g aunque
podemos tener dos valores en x
este valor mx que me apunté a un valor
en sí y otro valor diferente en x que me
apunté al mismo valor en b eso sí se
permite vamos a analizar nuestras
opciones damos la opción
vemos que para cada valor de x que está
en mi eje x solo hay un valor en sí aquí
aplicamos lo que se llama la prueba de
la línea vertical
si yo dibujo una línea vertical por cada
valor de x esta línea sólo va a ser
interceptada una vez por un valor en g
eso lo podemos hacer en todos estos
valores de x si llegara a existir
línea vertical que fuera interceptada
por dos valores en y entonces aquí
sabemos que no es una función aquí vemos
que hay un valor en este dos por ejemplo
que será para el valor por ejemplo se
valora en menos tres perdón por este
valor en tres y este dos también se da
para este valor que está entre bueno
aproximadamente aquí no está muy exacto
pero bueno aquí tenemos este valor de el
docente que existe para dos valores
diferentes de x pero esto está bien
ahora analicemos nuestra siguiente
opción nace que está aquí junto
aplicamos nuestra regla de la línea
vertical y vemos que igual para cada
valor en x sólo va a haber un valor en
ye que intersecta
estas líneas verticales para cada valor
en x
vemos aquí en esta opción en b y también
también a simple vista notamos que hay
un solo valor de hecho aquí hay un solo
valor de y para cada equis a no es como
estos casos que podemos tener un mismo
valor de parados x diferentes veamos
esta opción en de y vemos que aquí si ya
no se cumple la regla de la línea
vertical que es ahí no me quedo muy
vertical que digamos esta línea vertical
vemos que para un valor en x para este
uno tenemos dos valores
y aquí tenemos un 2 y un -2 y estos ya
no se cumple para una función así que la
respuesta de cuál de las siguientes no
es una función es la opción d